of my house yesterday although there
weren't a lot of people there happy with
them but they did it because there's not
a one of those officers I talked to that
wasn't sickened to the core about what
they witnessed and knowing that when
you're part of an organization the
culture permeates all of us a culture
that allows things to happen
a culture where the public cannot trust
and we know that this is systemic not
just in Minneapolis in Minnesota but it
needs to start somewhere it needs to
start where we know things happen and I
know what organizations look like when
you're serving I have served in some of
the finest organizations whether they
were public schools or whether it was in
the National Guard and the leadership
and the type of things you're committed
to make a difference and they can be
generational we know that deeply seated
issues exist and the reason I know it is
we saw the casual nature of the erasing
of George Floyd's life and humanity we
also know by the reaction of the
community they expected nothing to
happen and the reason is because nothing
did happen for so many times I hear and
listened and stood next to mothers who
lost their children in this and say so
many times as I heard mayor Carter say
I've heard others echo being black
should not be a death sentence and for
each and every one of us in law
enforcement you don't get judged right
on the spot especially with the finality
of being killed in police custody
so Minnesotans you can expect our
administration use every tool at our
disposal to try and deconstruct systemic
racism that is generations deep and as
we move forward we're going to need to
do it with the community but I think the
thing I'm hearing from the protesters is
well no we're not watching and we don't
care what you say we care what you do so
today as a step towards that
deconstruction of systemic racism the
Minnesota Department of Human Rights is
filing a commissioners charge of
discrimination to launch a civil rights
investigation into the Minneapolis
Police Department the investigation will
review MPD's policies procedures and
practices
over the last 10 years to determine if
the department is utilized to semuc
discriminatory practices towards people
of color Minnesota has one of the
strongest civil rights laws in the
country it is illegal for police
department to discriminate against
someone because of their race this is
the first time that the state is
launching a civil rights investigation
into the systemic discriminatory
practices of the largest police
department in the state it is also the
only investigation surrounding the
killings of George Floyd focusing on the
policies and practices implemented by
the Minneapolis Police Department when
the Minnesota Department of Human Rights
finds civil rights violations they seek
structural change to prevent
discrimination from occurring again the
Minnesota Department of Human Rights
will also seek an agreement with the
Minnesota Minneapolis Police Department
to implement interim measures
immediately in advance of long term
measures to address systemic
discriminatory practices this effort is
only one of many steps to come and our
efforts to restore trust within those
communities who have been unseen unheard
and believe that those that are charged
to serve and protect not only don't do
that they work against them and I say
this as a white man who walks through
that life with pretty much relative ease
I can't ever know the plain of that back
community members but I hear you I'm
listening and one of the things I need
to do is use that ability to change and
use that ability to build coalitions and
make this situation that has become
intolerable across the nation that will
not go away with tough talk and more
people on the streets in uniform it will
go away with a sense of community seem
being displayed upon the state capitol
lawn today with law enforcement and the
people that they serve seeing themselves
as neighbor in the same society and the
same opportunities for their children so
you're going to hear from a group of
leaders in here you're going to hear
from Commissioner Rebecca Lucero of the
Minnesota Department of Human Rights
you're going to hear from a community
leader whose voice booms throughout
these issues in Justin Tyrell and you're
going to hear from someone who has
walked with me and has let me see
through the eyes of a different
perspective and someone who's been at
the heart of these changes and asking
for these systemic changes lieutenant
governor Peggy Flanagan
good afternoon and thank you Thank You
governor the murder of George Floyd is a
tragedy it is heartbreaking and it
should have never happened but let's be
clear it does not exist in isolation
George Floyd George Floyd's name joins a
two long list of black men and women who
have been needlessly killed at the hands
of law enforcement across this country
the grief and anger that has torn
through our city and through our state
did not emerge in a vacuum it is built
on years of injustice this did not begin
with George Floyd but we can work to end
it now under the leadership of
Commissioner Rebecca Lucero
and the Department of Human Rights our
administration has launched a civil
rights investigation into the
Minneapolis Police Department not just
around one case but an investigation of
the past ten years what is clear is that
tragedies like the one that happened to
George Floyd do not emerge from a few
isolated bad actors but from patterns of
misconduct a culture and this is
cultural a culture that does not hold
bad behavior accountable this is not
something that we can fix in one day or
in one week but we must pursue
meaningful structural change
George Floyd deserves this of us and
every single person who is impacted by
this culture deserves this of us I said
this past Saturday that the swell of
mourning and grief and anger has been
just below the surface
in our state and now it has burst into
public and national view communities
have been asking and organizing for
structural change of the Minneapolis
Police Department for years their work
has paved the way for what we are
launching here today this is one piece
of the puzzle to getting justice for
George Floyd and all black Minnesotans
who have not been served or protected by
the Minneapolis Police Department it is
one piece of the puzzle to holding all
four officers accountable for George's
murder and changing the culture that
made them a culture that does not value
the lives of black Minnesotans as a
light skinned native woman I grapple
daily with my role and in particular
over the last week I have grappled with
my role as a light skinned native woman
but also as lieutenant governor of
Minnesota to do everything I can to undo
the anti blackness that lives within our
community and within our state this
action that we're taking today is one
tangible step forward that is critical
to correcting the injustice that plagues
us this problem has been years in the
making but we have an opportunity to
seize this moment to make it better to
take a solid first step of many many
steps that we must do in each branch of
government to deconstruct the system of
racism that frankly have always has
always existed in this state we can and
we must and we must take this
meant to change at all and with that I'd
like to introduce to you
Commissioner Rebecca Lucero of the
Minnesota Department of Human Rights
good afternoon my name is Rebecca Lucero
and I'm the Commissioner for the
Department of Human Rights I just want
to start real quick by holding space for
all the pair all the people that I carry
with me here today all my ancestors all
my community members and leaders who
have done the work for generations to
create a Beloved Community
I honor your work and I join with you in
solidarity as we continue to move
forward together as the Commissioner of
the Minnesota Department of Human Rights
my agency is charged with enforcing one
of the strongest civil rights laws in
the country the Minnesota Human Rights
Act and today we continue our ongoing
work to secure justice by announcing
that our department is opening a civil
rights investigation into the
Minneapolis Police Department under the
Minnesota Human Rights Act it is illegal
for a police department to discriminate
against someone because of their race
when our department finds civil rights
violations we seek structural change our
investigation will look at the
Minneapolis Police Department over the
past ten years to determine if they have
utilized systemic discriminatory
practices towards people of color we
will review the department's trainings
policies procedures and practices the
death of George Floyd is what launched
this in this investigation
George Floyd should be alive he deserved
to live a life full of dignity and joy
what we all know to be true what Mayor
Frye mayor Carter the governor
lieutenant governor and countless
community members have repeatedly
stressed is that what communities of
color and indigenous communities are
facing today is the direct result of 400
plus years of intentional decision
decisions to create and sustain systems
policies and processes that have
resulted time and time again in systemic
I don't want to exaggerate it how they
move it are they starting to move
West looks like it huh no
about Thailand
more units report in here was crazy at
the beginning
I'm symptomatic right now field tile
with little dry cough longer cotton is
really useful in copied was so eagerly
waiting long before returning back to my
hospital that is the waiting sing
forever to me we have to consider social
media as a new way alternative way to
learn is is the best way to share
experiences globally I had to get over
the laptop at some point pass all my
family all the members in my in my house
we gradually we cut the DC at some point
so the first one was me but then the
second width was another relative and
the third week was my wife so we have to
change the room to from the isolate the
room that we lived or for the isolation
to a different member each week now I
can share my experience with my presence
as well I can't be more empathic with
them after I recover I was able to go
back to my position at the front lines
of the merchant apartment and after that
I scan more than 200 patients with
copied so what I learned in this process
allow me to better understand the DC 5
percent of the population in Spain had
gone through the infection so I'm
someone special
disinformation alternative facts